قال اوس الخفاجي زعيم ميليشيا ابي الفضل
العباس العراقيه ان اصدار الرئيس الامريكي
قرار حضر دخول مواطني سبع دول اسلاميه كان
بسبب خوفه مما سماه المقاومه واشار الى ان
البوارج الامريكيه القريبه من اليمن مهدده
مؤكدا انتصار ما دعاه محور
المقاومه
كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ونناقش فيما
وراءه هل تؤشر هذه التصريحات الى اتجاه
لتصعيد دور الميليشيات المواليه لايران في
قضايا المنطقه الساخنه وكيف يمكن ان تؤثر
مثل هذه المواقف في قرارات الولايات
المتحده وحلفائها تجاه نفوذ ايران والقوى
المواليه
[موسيقى]
لها من لبنان اطلق اوس الخفاجي زعيم
ميليشيا ابي الفضل العباسي العراقيه
والقيادي في الحشد الشعبي اطلق تهديدات
للامريكيين نقلتها مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي عن قناه المسيره التابعه لجماعه
الحوثي اليمنيه مؤشرات تضم مناطق نفوذ
ايران الاقليمي في العراق ولبنان وسوريا
واليمن وياتي رصدها في ظل تصعيد خطابي حاد
بين ايران والولايات المتحده وبعد اتصال
هاتفي بين الرئيس الامريكي دونالد ترامب
ورئيس الوزراء العراقي حيدر العبادي بحث
في جانب منه ما وصف بالتهديد الذي تمثله
ايران لدول المنطقه فالى اين تتجه الامور
تقرير ناصر اي
الطاهر رموز المقاومه اجمع قطاع الاحجيه
على ارض لبنان ومن تلفزيون تابع لجماعه
الحوث اليمنيه يطل زعيم ميليشيا عراقيه
تقاتل في سوريا انها بحد ذاتها رساله
كانما استجمعت ايران هنا كل قواها
الاقليميه وقل اذا شئت اذرعها وتلك في
عقيده ايران كما يقول كثير من مسؤوليها هي
خط الدفاع الاول عن دوله الولي الفقيه
ادوات ذاك التصدي نفسها يستخدمها
الايرانيون الان في الحرب الكلاميه
المستعره مع الاداره الجديده في واشنطن
احداها ذهبت بعيدا منتشيه بما دعتها
انتصارات حلف المقاومه في سوريا والعراق
اذ وجهت تهديدا مباشرا الى البوارج
الامريكيه القريبه من اليمن تدرك ايران ان
التصعيد الامريكي الاخير لا يتعلق
بالاتفاق النووي حصره اما دخول الميليشيات
التابعه لها على خط التصعيد فليس دليلا
فحسب على ترابط عضوي لملفات المنطقه وانما
ايضا على لعب ايران ادوارا في كل منها عبر
وكلائها المحليين فهل لدى هؤلاء ما ينبغي
على واشنطن تخشاه لاول وهله سيبدو ان
ادوار تلك الميليشيات الناشطه على اكثر من
ساحه ستتعامل المقبله ولعلها ستعمل على
ارباك خطه الامريكيين وحلفائهم في المنطقه
قد تفعل ايران في العراق حيث تقوى نفوذها
السياسي والعسكري في عهد الاداره
الامريكيه السابقه وحيث بدا انها شكلت
حرسها الثوري الجديد بعد اقرار قانون
الحشد الشعبي كيف هو الحال هذه طلب من
حكومه توالي ايران لجم كيان مسلح من صنع
ايران ايضا لكنه للمفارق في حكم حليف
واشنطن في الحرب على تنظيم الدوله اما في
سوريا حيث تقاتل ميليشيا ابي الفضل العباس
مع حزب الله اللبناني الى جانب نظام الاسد
بدعم روسي هذه المره فقد يكون بوسعها
المضي في عرقله مساعي اي تسويه او اعاقه
خطه اقامه مناطق امنه وبوسع بق قيه
الادوات الايرانيه الاستمرار في العبث
بامن العرب وتجاهل اياديهم الممدوده لجسر
قضايا الخلاف بانتظار حدوث معجزه ينصح
مستشارو دونالد ترامب رئيسهم بعزل ايران
وذاك مبتغى سيمر حتما عبر قطع اذرعها في
المنطقه لكن خبراء ايرانيين بدوا مطمئنين
الى ان ترامب لن يذهب بعيدا في تلك
المواجهه ولعل السبب كما بدا لخبراء عارفي
هو ان نبرتها
العاليه قد تخبو في مرحله
ما نرحب بضيوفنا في هذه الحلقه من واشنطن
هارلن اولمن كبير الباحثين في المجلس
الاطلسي والمستشار السابق لوزير الدفاع
الامريكي من بيروت توفيق شومان الكاتب
الصحفي والمحلل السياسي اللبناني ومن
الكويت الدكتور عبد الله الشايجي استاذ
العلوم السياسيه في جامعه الكويت نبدا
بضيفنا من من بيروت
سيد توفيق شمان التصريح اطلق من لبنان ضد
الامريكيين عن اليمن من تيار عراقي معروف
هذه الخلطه المتعدده ما الذي
تعنيه تحيه اليك بدايه سيدي محمد وايضا
الى الى الزملاء الكرام انا اعتقد بانه
هذه الكلمه يعني انا سمعتها خمس مرات
حقيقه ومدتها دقيقه 12 ثانيه هي من وحي
مناسبه لها علاقه بال بالمقاومه لذلك ادرج
ما قاله في سياق هذه المناسبه على مستوى
الزمان وعلى مستوى المكان ايضا خارج اطار
المناسبه لا اعتقد بان لهذه الكلمه اي
ابعاد على الاطلاق لا من ناحيه القول بما
له علاقه باليمن ثم ناتي الى ذلك لاحقا
ولا ايضا بما له علاقه بالعراق ربما
تحديدا بالعراق ربما اتوقف عند نق نقطه
اساسيه ان هناك اشكال حقيقي بين الحشد
الشعبي
وبين وبين القوات الامريكيه والحكومه
العراقيه ايضا تحديدا ب بما يرتبط حصرا
بمعركه بمعركه الموصل وما حولها خارج هذين
الاطارين وحي المناسبه مكان المناسبه زمان
المناسبه وما له علاقه ايضا بالميداني
العراقيه لا اعتقد ان لهذه الكلمه اي
ابعاد لا سياسيه ولا امنيه ولا
عسكريه طالما المساله تراها بهذا الشكل
نسال ضيفنا في واشنطن سيد هار اولمن هل
يمكن ان ينظر في واشنطن الى هذا التصريح
دقيقه و ثانيه ضيفنا في لبنان يعتبر بانه
لا يجب ان يحمل اكثر مما يحتمل في سياق
المناسبه التي قيل فيها هل يمكن ان ينظر
الى ذلك كذلك في واشنطن
نعم في حقيقه الامر هذا تهديد لنقل
تهديد لا يحمل الكثير من الجديه والكثير
من التفاصيل نعلم ايران تفتقر للامكانيات
وحلفاؤها ايضا يفتقرون ل الامكانيات ل
توجيه ضربات موجعه لايران
الان نعلم ان هناك توتر ما بين ايران
والولايات المتحده بسبب سياسه ايران
الصاروخيه وهناك محاوله بعد الشيء لتوجيه
اشارات ورسائل لايران و لنهايه المطاف ما
سمعناه ولنقل انه اندار او صرخه في وادي
من قبل حلفاء ايران وهذا لن يؤثر بشكل
كبير على ال المتحده وعلى حلفاء في
المنطقه اذا الاداره الامريكيه لن تكترث
كثيرا لهكذا تصريحات
وهكذا اقوال لا يمكن ان تتبع افعال نعم
اذا نحن في هذه الحاله امام استهانه ان صح
التعبير بهذه التصريحات سواء من ضيفنا في
لبنان او من ضيفنا من من واشنطن ولكن
لاعتبارين
مختلفين سيد شاجي
تسايره في هذا
الاتجاه لا يعني هو التصريح اتى في سياق
واضح ذرع ايران في المنطقه الحشد الشعبي
يعني هو واضح جدا انه ينفذ مشروع ايراني
تحت غطاء محاربه داعش ومحاربه التطرف
الاسلامي الذي يلتقي مع اداره اوباما في
السابق حول محاربه داعش وهذا ما اكده
المرشد في ختابه رساله ته لاوباما قبل
عامين باننا كما قال له اوباما نتوصل
اتفاق نووي ثم نتفرغ لننسفنه لمحاربه داعش
يبدو ان ترامب غير هذه المعادله وغير
مقتنع بان ايران والحشد الشعبي
وميليشياتها التابعه لها والموالي لها في
كل الدول التي تفاخر بالهيمنه والسيطره
عليها من بغداد الى المتوسط والى اليمن
انه يعني مقتنع بذلك تصريحات يعني الخفاجي
للاسف يعني لا تاتي لا تقدم ولا تؤخر
كثيرا هي فقط شعارات لا يعني عفا عليها
الوقت المقاومه اي مقاومه قاعد يتكلم هو
مقاومه من متى اخر مره قاموا بالمقاومه
يعني هذا السؤال لم يعد او هذه شعار لم
يعد يعني يجدي نفعا بعدين اذا بقاتل
البوارج الامريكيه في اليمن يعني يوجد
5000 مقاتل امريكي موجودين في بلده في
العراق موجودين كخبراء ومستشارين يقدمون
من الخدمه ويتعاونون مع حكومه بلده حيدر
العبادي اللي اتصل فيه الرئيس ترامب قبل
اول امس و واخبره باننا سنرسل المزيد من
القوات اذا يبي يقاوم يقاوم القوات
الامريكيه الموجوده في العراق او الموجوده
في طول الساحل الخليجي وليس في اليمن يعني
بعدين امريكا ما عندها بوارج في اليمن ما
عندها امريكا هناك بارجه واحده المدمره
كول التي ضربتها القاعده وليس اي من
الحلفاء ايران الذين اعتدوا على الباخ
المدمر كول في عام 2000 وقتلوا 17 بحارا
نعم يعني على ذك على ذكر حلفاء ايران على
ذكر حلفاء ايران دكتور شاجي على ذكر حلفاء
ايران يعني المناسبه التي قيل فيها كلام
الخفاجي سيد توفيق
شومان قيل من
لبنان رغم انك اشرت الى ان المناسبه لا
تحتمل ان ان يحمل كلام الخفاجي اكثر مما
يحتمل ولكن ان يقال في لبنان وفي محفل لكل
الموالين لايران تقريبا بتسميات
مختلفه الا يعطي ايران لبنان مره اخرى وصف
البارومتر مثل ما اطلق عليه بعض المعلقين
الان عاد لبنان مره اخرى الى لعب دور
البارومتر وبالتالي هذا المؤشر حتى وان
كان خفيفا في سلم الحراره يجب ان يؤخذ
بعين
الاعتبار
يعني خلينا كمان سيدي محمد انا يعني اقول
بانه بما له علاقه برسم السياسات
الاقليميه انا اعتقد بانه سماحه السيد حسن
نصر الله هو الذي يقرر ذلك يعني ل على
المستوى الاقليمي وعلى المستوى اللبناني
مهما قيل الكلام من من بيروت اعتقد بانه
هو كلام يندرج في سياق تحليل سياسي معين
في سياق صرخه كما قال احد الزملاء ولكن
ايضا اود ان اشير الى ما له علاقه باليمن
هو لم هو قل حرفيا ان بوارج مهدده في
اليمن لم يقل بان العراقيين سوف يذهبون
للقتال في اليمن وبالتالي ليست هذه
البوارج وانا اتفق مع زميلي من الكويت بان
هناك بارجه واحده هي بارجه كول والتي
ارسلت مؤخرا الى ال الى الشواطئ اليمنيه
يعني كلامه محصور بانه بوارج مهدده في
اليمن ولم يقل باننا نهدد بوارج في اليمن
بمعنى ارسال مقاتلين العراقين السياق يفرض
علينا سيد شمان يعني هو لم يقلها يعني
اسمح لي ربما لم يقلها بهذا المعنى الصريح
ولكن السياق
العام يحتمل ذلك خاصه عندما يشيد
بالمقاومه ويربط قرار ترامب بمنع دخول
هؤلاء المواطنين من سبع دول بانتصار
المقاومه اذا هو في نفس نضالي بين قوسين
والحديث عن امريكا في سياق نفس نضالي يفرض
علينا هذا الفهم
لا صحيح ولكنه لانه يعتبر نفسه جزءا من
محور من محور مقاومه هو قال ان المقا
بمعنى انا افهم كلامه بانه هو يقول بان
البوارج الحربيه الامريكيه تحت مرمى
المقاومه او مهدده من قبل المقاومه هو
اعتبر بانه في اليمن هناك مقاومه وبالتالي
بان المقاومه اليمنيه هي التي هي التي
تهدد هذه البوارج في حال وهنا ايضا بيت
القصيد السياسي في حال انخرط
الامريكيون
مباشره في خط الازمه اليمنيه او في اتون
الازمه اليمنيه باعتباره احد الحشد الشعبي
احد اضلع او احد عناصر او احد جبهات
المقاومه كما يعتبر السيد اوس الخوجي
وبالتالي هو ينطلق من وحده الميداني ومن
وحده الساحات ومن وحده المعارك ومن وحده
المواجهات والجبهات ايض ن الم الملفت ايضا
نعم الملفت ايضا في في هذا التصريح سيد
اولمن
ان من يقوله هو جزء من الحشد الشعبي الحشد
الشعبي الذي تنظر اليه الولايات المتحده
على انه تنظيم منخرط في المؤسسه العسكريه
العراقيه الرسميه يقوله احد حلفاء العبادي
وهو حليف لواشنطن العراق كله وطبقته
السياسيه المهيمنه حليفه لامريكا الا
يعتبر هذا مستفزا في سياق علاقه خاصه ما
بين
العراق والولايات
المتحده اعتقد ان الولايات المتحده
والبحريه الامريكيه تحديدا تعلم وتعي جيدا
بان قواتها وسفنها في المنطقه قد تكون
هدفا لهجمات من قبل اعداء الولايات
المتحده في المنطقه نتذكر ما حدث مع فريجه
كول قبل سنوات واغراق تلك السفينه في
المياه الولايات المتحده حذره و وانتبه
بشكل كبير لذلك الولايات المتحده
لنتغير من منظورها في هذا السياق هناك
استعداد وتجهيز مستمر لمواجهه اي عدوان
على هذه البوارج الامريكيه في تقديري
قد تكون هذه التصريحات فقط رد فعل لما
سمعنا في الاونه الاخيره من خلال التوتر
الجاري ما بين ايران والولايات المتحده
ولكن في تقدير هذا لن يؤثر على جاهزيه
القوات الامريكيه على الرد على اي تهديد
قد يمس سفنها في المنطقه وهذه التصريحات
لن تلعب دور اساسيا في تغيير موازين
القوى على كل بعد الفاصل س نتساءل عن مدى
تاثر قرارات الولايات المتحده وحلفائها
تجا ايران بدور القوه والمليشيا الم
والمليشيات بالاحرى المواليه لها في
المنطقه لن
[موسيقى]
عوده
[تصفيق]
اهلا بكم من جديد مازلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نتناول فيها ابعاد تصريح اوز
الخفاجي زعيم ميليشيا ابي الفضل العباس
العراقيه الذي اطلقه من لبنان بان البوارج
الامريكيه القريبه من اليمن مهدده دكتور
عبد الله الشايجي بتقدير كيف يمكن ان
تتصرف دول الخليج امام هذا التسخين
الايراني الامريكي والان مع هذه الاشارات
لدور ما قد تطلع به الميليشيات والقوى
العسكريه المواليه
لطهران يعني انا في اعتقادي ما وصلنا اليه
هو حصاد الاستثمار الايراني في المنطقه
خلال السنوات او العقد الماضي باستخدام
ادواتها من دول ومن غير دول والقطر الاكبر
الان هو من الميليشيات من غير الدول التي
تنطلق من دول ولكن لا يمكن للدوله ان
تتحكم بقراراتها يعني لم نسمع ردا مثلا من
حيدر العبادي على ما قاله اوس الخفاجي
سواء اليوم او سواء عندما هدد باقتحام سجن
الناصريه وتنفيذ اعدامات او باغتيال
السفير السعودي يعني لم يكن هناك اي موقف
وكان الدوله الان اصبحت تختصر في العراق
بهذه الميليشيات حتى وصلنا الى الميليشيات
الحشد الشعبي المسيح حيه التي تهدد سكان
بعض القرى في
الموصل بضربهم دون ان يكون في رد فعل من
الحكومه العراقيه نفسها التهديد هو واضح
الان نحن الان نتعامل مع اخطر تهديد اللي
هو من مسميه في علم العلاقات الدوليه نون
ستيت اكتز اللاعبون من غير الدول وما
نسميه الحروب غير المتماثله السمتر ورفير
هذين التهديد هما اكبر تهديد يهددان كل
دول المنطقه بما فيه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وحربها على داعش لا يمكن ان
نتعامل معه بشكل فردي يجب ان يكون بشكل
جماعي ما تقوم به ايران الان وحلفائه هو
حرب او ضربه استباقيه قبل ان يعني يتم
تصنيفهم منظمات ارهابيه بدءا بالحرس
الثوري واذكر هن بان ايضا مايكل فلن
مستشار الامن الوطني في البيت الابيض وصف
الحوثيين بانهم جماعه ارهابيه مواليه
لايران يعني هنا يجب ان يكون الموقف واضح
دول مجلس التعامل الخليجي مهدده الان من
هذه ال التنظيمات غير الدول وراينا الان
على الحدود الكويتيه يوجد تحشيد امس
واليوم من قبل جماعات يعني ما يسمى هبه
لمطالبه بخور عبد الله ومن يحرك هؤلاء
والخلاف داخل البيت الشيعي الشيعي وراينا
ما جرى اليوم في بغداد من مقتل سبعه اشخاص
بصراع بين الصدريين وبين حزب الدعوه يعني
هناك الان في فلتان امني في العراق في
دوله اضعف من الميليشيات المسلحه واضعف من
الجيش العراقي وهذا يتكرر في المناطق
الاخرى علينا نحن الان ان يكون موقفنا
واضح في دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي في موقف
موحد يمكن ان نتعامل معه مع اذرع هذه
الاذرع المواليه لايران التي تستخدم
لتنفيذ مشروع للسيطره على المنطقه ويعني
انا متفائل الان ان الايرانيين امس لم
يصعدوا بشكل واضح لم يطلقوا صاروخا واحد
او لم يستعرضوا صاروخ واحد كما كانوا
يفاخر دائما في عرض يوم الثوره الذي يصادف
في العاشر من نوفم من فبراير يعني يوجد
الان نوعا من المهادنه من قبل ايران بعيدا
عن الحرب الكلاميه واللفظيه التي جرت خلال
الايام الماضيه بين الطرف الايراني والطرف
الامريكي اخذنا هذه المها ه هو تنفيذا
لكلام وتهديد ولايتي لان ايران سترد مع
حلفائها في المنطقه على اي اعتداء امريكي
هل هو هذا رساله ايرانيه بالدرجه الاولى
هذا هو السؤال نعم اذا اخذنا ما سميته
المهادنه مقابل
صعود دور تنظيمات غير الدول سيد توفيق
شمان المعروف تقليديا عن
الايرانيين ابداعهم ان صح التعبير في
تحريك هؤلاء وفي توجيه رسا رسائل من من
خلالهم اذا اخذنا ما قاله الدكتور شاجي
بان ايران ربما لن لم تكن في وارد التصعيد
في هذه الايام ولكن ان تاتي هذه الت
تصريحات وكانها ربما ربما تشير الى ان
لدينا موالون بامكانهم ان يزعجكم او ان
يؤذوك دون ان تتورط ايران بالضروره
في اتهام مثل هذا هل هذا
وارد هلا بالاست بالاستنتاج بدون شك انه
يمكن يمكن الوصول الى استنتاج من هذا
النوع او الى نتيجه من هذا النوع ولكن
كرساله فعليه او عمليه او كرساله سياسيه
ضمن السياق العام او ضمن الاطار العام انا
بامكاني ان اؤكد نفي ذلك بامكاني ان انفي
ذلك الامر ليس له علاقه ب يعني بالرساله
الفعليه او بالرساله المضموني لما قاله
السيد اوس الخفاجي انا قلت بانه هذا الامر
جاء في سياق مناسبه ما في مكان ما لذلك
كان حفلا خطابيا تم اطلاق هذه المواقف ضمن
هذه المناسبه المكانيه والزمانيه ولكن انا
اود ان اقول نعم ربما هذا الجانب الثاني
الذي تريد الاجابه عليه او ربما الذي ربما
لابد من الاجابه عليه انه في حال تطورت
المواجهه اللفظيه او الحرب الكلاميه كما
وصفها زميلي السيد الشايجي من الكويت الى
حرب عمليه اعتقد نعم بان حلفاء ايران في
المنطقه لن ي لن يقفوا مكتوفي الايدي
ولكني انا من القائلين بان هذه الحرب
الكلاميه وكل السياسه الحربيه على مستوى
المواقف وعلى مستوى المطالبه بعزل ايران
من قبل الاداره الامريكيه الجديده لا
اعتقد بان الامر يمكن ان يصل الى حد
المواجهه المباشره بين الاداره الامريكيه
وبين ايران الان الامور اعتقد بانه اقل
حده مما كانت عليه على سبيل المثال قبل
الاتفاق النووي وبالتالي لم يذهب
الامريكيون والايرانيون منذ اندلاع الثوره
الاسلاميه في ايران واسقاط نظام الشام الى
مواجهه عسكريه اعتقد بان لدى الطرفين يعني
من الحكمه التي تؤدي الى من ع وصول الامر
الى هذه المواجهه المباشره ولكن لا يعني
ذلك بان الامريكيين لا ينطلقون الان في
سياستهم تجاه ايران على محور محاصره
النفوذ الاقليمي لايران او اضعاف النفوذ
الاقليمي لايران دون ان يعني ذلك مره اخرى
واخيره دون ان يعني ذلك المواجهه المباشره
او الوصول الى المواجهه المباشره لا
الامريكيون يريدون ذلك ولا الايرانيون
ايضا بهذا الوارد نعم ولكن في في في سياق
الموقف الامريكي السيد هارلن اولمن واشنطن
عندما ترصد الوضع
الاقليمي هل تاخذ بعين الاعتبار من
الناحيه الرسميه ايران طبعا وتصريحاتها
ولكن هل تاخذ بالاعتبار ايضا تصريحات من
قبيل الصادره عن تنظيمات مواليه لايران
حزب
الله اوس
الخزرجي غيره من من تنظيمات تدين بالولاء
لطهران اعتقد اننا علينا ان ننظر الى
الموضوع من طريقه بطريقه مختلفه هناك
الكثير من النزاعات في المنطقه الازاعه
السوريه وايضا تنظيم الدوله وايران ايضا
الان لايران وال
المتحده لنقل مصلحه من من اجل انهاء
النزاع في سوريا وايضا من اجل مكافحه
تنظيم الدوله هذا هو الشيء الاساسي اما
فيما يتعلق باليمن فاليمن يعتبر مسرح
مواجه ما بين العربيه السعوديه وايران
وهذه النزاعات كلها بالتاكيد
تزيد تزيد قتمه على المنطقه وتزيد من
التعقيد الوضع هناك اولويات
لاداره ترامب ربما اول هذه الاولويات هي
مكافحه تنظيم الدوله واتمنى ان تبقى هذه
الاولويه هي التي يجب التركيز عليها من
قبل الاداره اما مواضيع اخرى فلا اعتقد
انها ستكون مجديه في الوقت الراهن بالنسبه
للاداره الامريكيه بالنسبه للاتفاق النووي
ليست الولايات المتحده هي الطرف الوحيد في
هذا الاتفاق لان لدينا هناك خمس اطراف
اخرى وقعت على هذا الاتفاق اذا انا استبعد
ان يتم الخوض في هذا الموضوع
الان
والموضوع الهام والاساسي الان هو ان تتمكن
المنطقه من التخلص من مساله تنظيم الدوله
وان تتكاتف الجهود لحل
هذا المشكل الذي بات يؤرق كل الاطراف في
المنطقه ا وايضا ال المتحده شكرا لك شك
شكرا لك معذره شكرا لك سيد هارلن اولمن
شكرا ايضا لتوفيق شومان وشكرا ايضا
للدكتور عبد الله
الشايجي با امان
[موسيقى]
الله y